bonsoir monsieur mon grand soir mais ses
clients d'emblée j'ai le goût de vous
poser la question comme cela si les
pétrolières étaient encore très rentable
pour vous est ce que vous auriez fait la
même annonce aujourd'hui
écoutez je pense que c'est une stratégie
qui est ambitieuse qui est pragmatique
dont qui est ancré dans la réalité et l
a4 volée et ses quatre volets lost
complètent l'un l'autre sont
essentielles comme vous en parliez un
peu plus tôt et je pense que à terme on
croit que le modèle pétrolier la
production de pétrole aussi l'offre de
pétrole est un modèle d'affaires qui pas
soutenable à long terme qui est pas
durable qui nous qui nous approchent pas
notre objectif ultime qui est un futur
durable nette zéro en carbone en 2050
alors vous savez le fait de l'argent
avec ce secteur là à travers ces cycles
on va être capable de rester exposés aux
mêmes cycles sans être exposé
nécessairement au pétrole alors pour
nous ça combine deux choses ça amène des
rendements supérieurs à nos déposants en
allant vers les énergies vertes le
renouvelable et ce à des risques
également le portefeuille sur certains
aspects qu'on juge problématique à long
terme ce qui vous vaut aujourd'hui une
ovation debout des écologistes des
environnementalistes qui salue avec
enthousiasme le geste de la caisse de
dépôt en retour quel message ça on voit
à l'industrie pétrolière aux
travailleurs de l'énergie en alberta
notamment
une chose qui est importante de dire au
delà de la sortie de la production de
pétrole est également le fait qu'on ne
financera pas de nouveau projet de
pipeline notre capital demeurent
disponibles pour cette industrie pour
des projets de transition et on le fait
avec certains joueurs je pense à bp
entre autres ou est ce qu'on a investi
avec eux dans leur plate-forme la
d'énergie solaire alors ce capital là il
est disponible ce qu'on fait simplement
dire si on va le faire avec les
entreprises qui sont sérieuses dans
cette transe son look on se doit
d'avancer le plus tôt possible donc pour
la transition mais voyez-vous
l'association d'énergie du québec disait
aujourd'hui il y en a d'autres qui vont
profiter de la place laissée par la
caisse et l'opep dit la demande
pétrolière mondiale va continuer de
progresser d'ici à 2040 5 vous êtes à
l'aise avec ses projections là et avec
votre décision
oui pour nous il n'ya pas un compromis
ou un coût d'opportunité
si on regarde nos rendements ont été en
infrastructures en immobilier entre
autres dans le dernier semestre porté
par les énergies renouvelables par les
secteurs du rab des actifs vers et nous
ce qu'on croit we've ivan il va avoir
encore la demande pour ces énergies là
parce qu'il faut être honnête monsieur
fillion 80 % de l'offre énergétique sur
la planète c'est de l'énergie fossile
oui charbon on en est sorti pétrole on
en parlait reste le gaz naturel 5%
seulement c'est le renouvelable alors il
ya beaucoup de croissance mais c'est
pour ça qu'on reste dans les pipelines
existants puisque ça répond à une
demande donc on va être investi dans un
bridge par exemple qui amène un bon
dividende qui doit répondre à la demande
on peut pas couper cette offre lui
immédiatement on jetterait l'économie à
terre donc on essaie d'atteindre un
équilibre pourquoi vous sortez pas du
gaz naturel
est pour nous le gaz naturel quand on
enlève l'énergie fossile qui 80 % de
l'offre énergétique le charbon sera très
polluant le pétrole on vient d'en parler
le gaz reste l'alternative la moins
polluante
dans ce volet là et de se rendre de 5 %
renouvelable à 100 % ça va prendre des
années et aussi le fait que le gaz
naturel c'est la seule option qui reste
un parfois dans certains secteurs
industriels sur une grosse fonderie se
prend tellement de puissance lectrices
et pau suffisant alors il pas d'autres
alternatives donc dans d'autres causes
on est investi par dont les noms mais
donc vous vous considérez c'est une
énergie de transition le gaz naturel
parce que bien des gens considèrent
d'abord que c'est une énergie fossile et
que le chemin à faire la suite c'est gaz
naturel
mais probablement que c'est une histoire
qui va s'écrire pays est toujours ses
débuts notre frontière puis dans dix ans
on sera ailleurs mais prenez également
le gaz naturel d'un point de vue parfois
par région géographique
au brésil on est investi dans le gaz
naturel et on l'hydroélectricité comme
au québec mais en beaucoup plus de
sécheresse qui si une période de l'année
on préfère qu'ils aillent dans le gaz
naturel que dans le charbon alors il
faut aussi leur garde et d'un point de
vue géographique parce que
personne n'était au même endroit mais
dans 10 ans ou est ce qu'on sera bien
c'est un débat qui poursuit toujours son
prochain chapitre est ce qu'il y aura un
coût de votre décision d'aujourd'hui sur
le rendement il ya quand même quatre
milliards à déplacer relativement
rapidement je sais pas si vous faites ça
régulièrement déplacés 4 milliards de
dollars d'investissements mais ce qui
rend un coup à sa sur le rendement de la
caisse
il faut le mettre dans l'ordre de
grandeurs service est à peu près une
dizaine de types des positions 300 400
millions portefeuille de la caisse bouge
quand même faut comprendre qu'on avait
entamé cette sortie là au fil des ans
même si je reviens très récemment pour
rassurer les gens on ferait pas une
stratégie comme ceux ci avaient un coût
négatif la première objectif c'est des
rendements long terme pour les dépose
prenez par exemple pendant la pandémie
beaucoup de gens ont dit on a perdu de
l'argent dans le pétrole vous devez
vendre le prix du pétrole des négatifs
on a attendu on le gardait en 2020 ne
tous récupérés çà et là le prix du
pétrole est élevé et yonne fneich on va
toujours faire même sur notre prime
décision appréciée l'exécution et
l'exécution les faits de façon tactique
aux pertes de capital et garder des
rendements pour me dépose en soucier
c'est toujours la marche a su vous
mettez la capture du carbone captage de
carbone dans vos investissements verts
est-ce que c'est pas un peu
contradictoire quand même le captage de
carbone la solution dite écologique le
du secteur du pétrole
dans le secteur du pétrole c'est israël
à la capture du carbone junte et serait
pas nous intéresserait pas parce que ça
fait simplement rendre moins pire
quelque chose qu'on considère pas
acceptable dans d'autres industries par
exemple la capture du carbone amène des
éléments très intéressants sinon ce
serait contradictoire dans notre
approche donc c'est pour les autres
secteurs c'est pas pour le pétrole et
pour les autres secteurs que vous voulez
miser sur la capture du carbone
exactement ok parfait précision clair
merci charlemont d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir pour nous parler de cette étape
quand même très important dans
l'histoire de la caisse de dépôt merci
c'est fait merci au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne i r d